if you want to hear the secrets behind
the demon that possessed the Annabelle
doll then stick around to the end of
this video I don't know why I'm doing
this I hope you weren't tired of
possessed doll movies after all those
childsplay episodes I just released
because playtime is not over quite yet
today on things you missed I'll be
covering Annabelle Annabelle is a series
spun off from James wands the conjuring
and this story contains plenty of covert
references Easter eggs and links to real
world mythology we'll start at the
chronological beginning where the
opening title is displayed over this
demonic looking statue this guy looks
exactly like Malthus the actual demon
that Mia first discovers in the storage
area so I think that this guy like his
counterpart VALIC from the known has
been around for a long long time and
someone many years ago encountered this
demon and made the statue to depict him
the father gives his sermon where he
tells of the commandment that you love
one another as I have loved you greater
love hath no one than this that he lay
down his life for his friends this is a
foreshadowing of the end of the movie
where Evelyn does just that gives up her
life to try to save John and Mia's baby
after the church service Mia goes to
find her neighbor Sharon Higgins
Rohit's send you after me I swear one
day he thinks out just although we don't
know it yet she's talking about their
daughter Annabelle Higgins who ran away
as a teenager
later mentions that she had run off to
join up with the hippies but she's
actually left to join up with a cult
known as the disciples of ran if you
listen to the TV playing in the
background at the house it reveals more
information about this cult they call
themselves the family but police
officials have labeled them as a
dangerous cult residing on the grounds
of Spahn Ranch the family is estimated
to have close to 30 members who are
responsible for the Tate and LaBianca
their leader is Charles Manson and
they're involved in satanic activities
there are a couple of instances in
Annabelle where the TV predicts what's
gonna happen next and this is one of
them the runway Annabelle Higgins brings
another cult member along as they kill
her parents then go next door to attack
the pregnant Mia one more important
detail Annabelle dives with the doll in
her arms giving off the illusion that
she transferred the demon into Annabelle
in prequel Annabelle creation we find
out about how Annabelle Higgins was
possessed by the demon but that doesn't
explain how John ended up with the doll
he gives it to his wife as a gift but
doesn't really explain where he found it
but if you find her I mean do you know
how long I've been looking I don't think
this is a coincidence we also don't find
out how the doll ended up going from
Evelyn's dying arms to this collector's
shop at the end of the movie or how it
got from the trash can to John's new
apartment so my theory is that the demon
is looking for families that he thinks
are vulnerable Mia and John weren't good
candidates because she was already a
doll collector and they lived next door
the Higgins's so they could see the
murders take place and thus be more
likely to believe that something and
possessed the doll because remember it's
explained at the beginning of the
conjuring that the demon doesn't really
possess the doll but it just moves it
around to try to trick people into
offering up their souls Annabelle is
found dead holding the doll in the
nursery with this symbol on the wall if
you rotate it it looks like the letter a
the symbol reappears throughout the
movie like the scar on Mia's arm after
being attacked by Malthus and one of the
images in the book that Mia reads to
investigate the occult and the disciples
of RAM the letter A also appears near
the end of the movie after the nursery
has been attacked there's a big a block
that has never been there before and the
baby's name starts with L not a one more
note on the attack the cult member
accompanying Annabelle has a ram belt
buckle an early clue that the cult is in
fact performing some kind of ritual
involving Malthus and as the detective
puts it later on their act wasn't
devotional that they were they were
actually trying to conjure something up
like that's what the devil demons the
tooth fairy I don't know specifically I
can't wait for the conjuring spinoff on
the tooth fairy I'm turning up on day
one for that one let's look at some of
the repeated symbols throughout the
house we see this a lot in the movies
that we cover here on things you missed
but there are tons of flower images
decorating the house we keep seeing them
over and over and over again there are
also a lot of butterfly images and when
you put these two together you have a
pollination and fertility metaphor which
goes along with the newborn baby being
the central focus of this film the other
symbol I saw ton of in the house was
owls these are hidden everywhere they
show up so much that I have no doubt
that they're meant to be noticed but how
do you interpret them may vary I see
them as mysterious nocturnal creatures
much like the demons of the conjuring
universe howls are often seen as symbols
of wisdom and father pairs later tells
them the more they know about their
enemies the less they will fear them we
need to face our fears the great thing
about the father is that he always talks
like that like even in regular
conversation imagine if I did that in my
videos here lies the things you missed
that have been bestowed upon us by the
director John leonetti who also made
Mortal Kombat annihilation I'm done
after the demon starts a fire that burns
up the house amia has the baby and they
move into the Palmeri apartments the
name Palmeri refers to the cleric who
carries a palm branch in religious
ceremonies and other tie into the
religious themes of the movie the doll
somehow follows them there and as I
mentioned earlier some satanic symbols
start to show up
I think these light ballasts resemble
the number six and there seem to be
three of them 666 they also live on the
sixth floor and when Mia encounters
Malthus downstairs she gets into the
elevator and mashes the sixth button
three times the scene also gives us our
best look at Malthus we usually only see
him manipulating the Annabelle doll and
occasionally using the forms of
Annabelle Higgins as I did for VALIC in
my video on the nun I'll bring up the
lights so we can get a better look at
the true form this demon seems to have
claw-like hands and the ability to climb
on walls or ceilings you may have also
missed the demon hiding behind the
curtain when amia turns off the record
player
if you pause when me is flipping through
the devil's welcome the book which is
basically the movie equivalent of the
Lesser Key of Solomon you can find more
information about Malthus and the
disciples of RAM to put it into
easy-to-understand terms it basically
says that there are rules and you have
to agree to give up your soul to this
demon before he can possess you if you
do it's everlasting so there's no going
back
no crossed fingers clause nothing to get
you out of this deal the making of this
deal is something that the church fears
the disciples can summon the demon by
shedding one's blood which is what we
saw at the beginning of the movie but
this is only to be done as a sacrifice
to Malthus not for food unless this is
meat given to them by the demons
specifically for food and he basically
wants to take over every living creature
on earth eventually the picture depicts
the detail that we eventually learned
from father Perez
that a baby doesn't really know how to
agree to give up its soul so it could
potentially be an easier target though
that doesn't seem to be the case for Lia
flipping through some of the other pages
to the devil's welcome we can see other
connections and other demons the image
of the snake eating its tail is
something that's seen many times in
connection with a ballot the marquee of
snakes who appears in the conjuring -
and a nun alongside the same image of
the snake there's also an illustration
of Bella the mighty King of Hell and
mention of Belial a demon without a
master on the next page there's Abaddon
the angel of the abyss unfortunately the
page in the Tooth Fairy is missing but I
do think all of these demons that it
does show are all good candidates to be
the antagonists of future conjuring
universe movies one of the other books
on the shelf and Evelyn's store is
called ghosts spirits and apparitions by
Anthony estreno Anthony estreno is the
name of a writer for a series called a
Mentalist which is about a famous
psychic much like Lorraine Warren is in
this universe this isn't a real book by
the way they just borrowed his name
Florence the name of father Paris's
apartment complex is the Barclay a
reference to Andy Barclay the main
character of the child's life franchise
which is the other major killer doll
movie series that exists so nice to see
them pay a little homage when they tell
the father of the occurrences that have
been going on he says he doesn't know
how to stop the demon but someone at the
church might relax
couple that the churches worked with in
the past to deal with this type of thing
they're back East but a call can always
be placed he's referencing the Warrens
the main characters of the mainline
conjuring films who live in Connecticut
now remember how I said that the TV can
be a sign of things to come the General
Hospital clip that plays all Mia's
asleep on the couch leads up to the
sequence where father Parris tries
taking the doll to the church with the
belief that he can weaken it that way
and then gets air heated straight into
the hospital where John is working so
that leaves Mia and Evelyn to fight off
the demon on her own Mia is about to
give the demon her soul in exchange for
her baby but Evelyn sacrifices herself
instead that he lay down his life for
his friends or in this case her friends
however as we know all this does is
transfers the demon to someone else also
do they not get blamed for killing
Evelyn I mean maybe they should have
thought that one through a little bit
more we don't see the scene where I'm
assuming me and John are taken away in
handcuffs instead we skip forward a
little under a year to this woman
entering a collector's shop in the
background you can spot the actual
Raggedy Ann doll this is the supposedly
haunted doll in real life that the movie
is based on but because of licensing
issues and in order to make it look more
creepy they made Annabelle a porcelain
doll for the movies this woman buys the
doll for her daughter who is a nurse I'm
just trying to find something for my
daughter Thanks she's a nurse always
helping people the women who explain
their paranormal experiences with
Annabelle in the opening scene of both
in this movie and the conjuring are
nurses for nurses we help people so one
of them must be this woman's daughter I
also find it interesting that we never
see the cashier who sells Annabelle to
the old woman on screen maybe the demon
took over this cashier in order to pass
on Annabelle to a new family just as Jon
mysteriously found the doll that his
wife was looking for let me know your
thoughts on that in the comments and
please subscribe to seize these worlds
for new Horrors every week because next
week I'll be covering the prequel
Annabelle creation remember to ring that
death Bell for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]